mais qui voit là aujourd'hui c'est
monsieur gros qui revient oui je sais
j'ai pas trop trop trop présent je vous
le dis bien je suis là aujourd'hui pour
vous parler des nouveaux iphone d'apple
parce que oui vous le savez le mois
d'octobre c'est le mois où on a les
iphone où on peut en parler on peut les
regarder on peut les toucher et moi ce
qui va m'intéresser c'est de comprendre
en quoi c'est nouvelle série d'iphone
ses iphone 12 vont être un des best
seller d'apple au niveau des iphone vont
être les iphone qui vont plus se vendre
et c'est une certitude donc on va se
parler de ça en ouvrant cette jolie
petite boîte que j'ai reçu de la part
d'apple tu commences à un petit pas
l'ouvrir gagner très rapidement mais je
vais regarder la suite avec vous on va
donc se regarder ses nouveaux iphone
d'apple on les a pas tous on à l'iphone
12 et on à l'iphone 12 pro le max et
mini arriveront ultérieurement mais vous
allez voir il ya plein de belles
surprises et surtout on va vraiment se
poser cette question pourquoi est ce que
ces nouveaux iphone 12 vont faire partie
des meilleures ventes au niveau des
efforts de tous les temps pour apple
regardez moi ce petit carton comme il l'
union on va l'ouvrir ne pas faire trop
trop de temps à l'intérieur il ya ça
alors ça normalement s'est posée là mais
ça glisse est donc ici on va avoir la
toute première boîte de l'iphone et tac
en lourd on a ici l'iphone 12 je trouve
que la boîte est beaucoup plus fine que
ce qu'on avait les années précédentes
donc ça c'est cool on va s'ouvrir dans
quelques instants et surtout intérieur
garder mon lit ça là on va continuer à
rédiger le nouveau chargeur magnétique
pour venir charger vos iphone par
induction sans contact donc ça c'est
aussi très très cool on va s'organiser
dans quelques instants voyez il nous met
à l'arrière vous le recharger en usb
c'est vous le branchez sur un bloc 20
watts et c'est parti mon kiki ok parfait
ensuite il a brillé je n'ai plus du tout
ouvert alors ça on retrouve une jolie
petite boîte signé apple alors attendez
il faut nourrir sa tac on ouvre vient là
montier la pin up à eau ah ouais ça
c'est aussi très jolie j'adore ont
toujours les écoutants intérieur message
où il a déjà vu ça je trouve ça très
très beau la boîte est magnifique et
surtout je suis toujours une fois de
plus surpris par la finesse des boîtes
j'ai l'impression que c'était là
l'épaisseur des boîtes de l'année
dernière que je peux avoir aujourd'hui
avec deux iphone alors que j'ai des
balles qui sont vraiment tout petit il
nous annonçait un peu effectivement dans
des iphone les plus petits les plus fins
en tout cas j'avais fabriqué par apple
en face aussi une très très bonne
nouvelle et nous on y croit ici des
coques de protection à
très chouette on a une coque de
protection en silicone blanc mac c'est
effectivement tout pouvoir venir le
recharger rires votre comme ça c'est
bien et vous avez exactement la même
dans ce petit bleu qui est très jolie
puisqu'on parle de coques de protection
c'est l'instant sponso avec mon
partenaire rhino chine parce que oui
vous propose également des coques de
très bonne qualité pour venir protéger
votre smart share inochi je vous cache
pas que cette année ils ont quand même
mis le paquet pour vous proposer des
protections fournir protéger
complètement et globalement votre iphone
mais avant qu'on ait plus loin pour
regarder comment est-ce que c'est comme
de rhinos ils devront s'adapter sur nos
iphone on va déjà regardé nos iphone et
moi j'ai vraiment hâte alors déjà je
vous le dis chaque année le doxie est
vraiment très très bon parce qu'ils ont
une conception d'oracle au niveau du
papier ou le laki se déballe extrêmement
facilement ça s'est accéléré ah ouais
j'adore toujours l'expérience chez apple
c'est très minimaliste a je pense qu'on
est effectivement des boîtes beaucoup
plus fine parce qu'on n'a pas de blog de
charge et ça c'est un peu ce que fait
regretter cette année chez apple c'est à
dire que vous avez effectivement votre
câble là on est effectivement sur du
lightning avec de l'autre côté fait
savoir via son petit lapin
qu'est ce qu'on a ici lightning usb
c'est ça ça marche maintenant il n'y a
plus de blocs de charge directement dans
vos boîtes d'un iphone et ça c'est
dommage c'est dommage parce
qu'effectivement on voit que les prix
restent sensiblement les mêmes mais par
contre les accessoires dix minutes donc
il faut que vous veniez acheter votre
blog de charges en plus et ça c'est
vraiment dommage parce que ça vient
changer un peu expérience et c'est
vraiment le point de regret que j'ai là
dessus à côté de ça le produit en
lui-même est plutôt alléchant plutôt
intéressant reste vraiment dans ce qu'on
avait effectivement l'année dernière le
design est inchangé on va s'allumer
d'ici quelques instants le bouton sur le
côté on va retrouver les haut parleurs
on va retrouver ici une prise l'iphone
vous le voyez vous à votre petit bouton
ici pour mettre en multi ou pas vos
boutons de volume ok très bien moi
j'aime beaucoup un produit vraiment très
cool dès à présent et très très bonne
donc là on est sur l'iphone 12
maintenant on va passer ici sur l'iphone
12 pro life en 12 pro version pacific
blue gellini version 512 il ya de
stockage mais quel que soit votre
capacité de stockage das un change
absolument rien rôle
j'aime vraiment vraiment vraiment se
produire très très joli ça c'est cool un
très très très bien bossé de la part
d'apple on a ce dôme at assez bien parce
que pas de traces de doigts le blog
photo avec votre trip le module photo
caméra principale tel objectif ultra
grand temps on à la caméra lidar juste
là on doit voir un micro ici qui est
planqué juste d'un point votre flash
très efficace on exactement la même
chose sur les côtés le bouton pour
l'allumer pour l'éteindre votre bouton
pour activer désactiver le sont les
réglages au niveau du volume je sors mon
iphone on se promet axe là j'ai un
iphone 12 pro donc forcément le mcs sera
beaucoup plus grand mais l'iphone 12 pro
mac sortira plus tard donc on va pas
pouvoir les comparer directement ça
c'est vrai que c'est drôle parce que
quand je les prends comme ça en fait
j'ai pas l'impression qu'une grosse
grosse différence au niveau de
l'épaisseur sensation de prise en main
est vraiment différente bon une fois de
plus là on est sur du max donc on est
sur autre chose mais voyez pareil dôme
at on a la même taille ici au niveau du
logo ce qui a vraiment changé c'est le
lac à meyrin lidar ici quand pouvoir
utiliser pour la réalité augmentée qu'on
va également pouvoir venir utiliser et
bien pour prendre des mesures chez vous
pour pas mal d usage différent et ça on
l'avait déjà avec l'ipad pro et va
pouvoir le faire également avec un
iphone donc ça c'est très très cool pour
écouter de ce point de vue là je suis
assez conquis je voulais zachée
rhinochill vous avez de quoi protéger
vos iphone et ça c'est cool on a ici des
protections d'écran parce que oui il
faut venir protéger le dos de votre
smartphone à grâce aux coques et je
voulais monde en quelques instants mais
l'écran aussi ça peut être vraiment
intéressant de venir protéger parce que
s'ils tombent sur la face avant est bien
ça peut venir vous inviter quelques
petites déconvenues on a donc des
protections d'écran aussi valable pour
l'iphone 12 et les fon 12 pro ça se
passe comme ça vous venez vous l'ouvrez
vous nettoyez votre écran vous ne posez
votre protection sur votre écran est
comme ça vous partez vous êtes
tranquille vous avez tout le kit
d'installation à l'intérieur on vous
explique comment ça marche vous avez
également les impacts scream protector
sera encore plus résistant qu'un une
protection d'écran classique donc si
vous pensez vous êtes à risque ça vaut
le coup d'investir ensuite on va
retrouver bien écouter de la coque de
protection ça on connaissait déjà vous
venez vous le prenez vous le mettez sur
votre iphone vous l'insérer vous avez
votre blog photos qui dépasse et votre
iphone est complètement protégés de
parents pas en ayant toujours accès à
vos différents boutons et vous avez
également les modèles x les mots d'eric
sont intéressants parce que vous venez à
serrer autour de votre iphone mais vous
gardez toujours
le dos visible si vous voulez retrouver
votre couleur alors là j'ai un petit
mélange rouge et bleu vous pouvez venir
choisir la couleur qui vous intéresse il
ya beaucoup de références sur le site de
rhinau chine vous avez un lien en bas
d'un description surtout vous avez un
code promo et oui vous pouvez l'acheter
moins cher grâce à rhinau shield et
monsieur gros ça c'est très très cool a
laissé un triplé dans la description
vous ne le regretterez pas pendant que
je démarrais que je configure mon nouvel
iphone je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
est ce que ce nouvel iphone d'apple
point ses nouveaux iphone d'apple va
faire partie de ceux qui vont se vendre
le plus déjà à voir si tu as un peu
l'histoire vous connaissez l'arrivée
d'apple avec ses iphone c'est 2007
c'était il ya déjà 13 ans autant vous
dire qu'il s'est passé pas mal de choses
en 13 ans on a vu arriver un iphone tous
les ans avec je dirais un vrai
changement une vraie explosion un modèle
très fort au niveau de l'iphone dix
c'était les 10 ans de l'iphone c'était
un produit différent qu'on retrouve
aujourd'hui bien évidemment avec ce
design avec faith heidi une innovation
très importante du côté de chez apple je
pense que l'innovation la plus
importante qu'on a pu retrouver avant
c'était l'arrivée de tochigi pour venir
des dérouillées grâce à son empreinte
digitale alors ses iphone qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont différents et en quoi est-ce
qu'ils vont être je dirais intéressant
et pourquoi il faut se positionner vous
le savez chez apple il ya toujours des
innovations qui arrive une année après
l'autre les iphone sont toujours plus
puissants sont toujours plus performants
ont toujours d écran de meilleure
qualité iront toujours plus loin au
niveau de la photo mais également au
niveau de la vidéo et je puis vous le
dire moi ça me fait quasiment un an que
apple m'a gentiment prêté l'iphone on se
promet axe et je vais vous dire pourquoi
est ce que moi je l'utilisent au
quotidien tout simplement parce que
aujourd'hui pour moi et pour mon usage à
moi c'est une des meilleures solutions
pour venir faire de la vidéo sur
instagram avant que j'utilise mon iphone
j'avais des vidéos sur internet n'était
pas de bonne qualité on enlève son bord
des gros pixels et c'est vraiment ce que
je n'ai approché alors aujourd'hui on
est effectivement que sur android les
constructeurs font beaucoup d'efforts
pour avoir des smartphones qui sont
meilleurs en vidéo maintenant le
problème c'est l'application instagram
puisque instagram doit développer une
application qui va être compatible avec
beaucoup de smartphones du marché tandis
qu'apple et bien ils ont une seule
application qui est disponible pour
uniquement leurs produits ce qui leur
permet de beaucoup mieux l'intégrer et
pour moi il y avait une vraie grosse
différence au niveau de la vidéo et
c'est pour ça que je me suis positionné
chez apple alors au delà du fait que je
monte sans faille à cut pro que
l'écosystème apple me va très bien et
que c'est une super solution que ça
marche pas très bien le bascule ç'a
vraiment été la vidéo pour les
historiens s'aggrave mais ça correspond
à moi à mes usages et à mon métier alors
moi justement je veux qu'on parle de cet
iphone iphone là ça va être une des
meilleures ventes pour apple au niveau
de l'histoire des iphone le deuxième
iphone souvenez vous c'était l'iphone 3g
on n'avait pas la 3g sur le premier
iphone on avait une collection qui était
pas très rapide avec l'iphone 3g on est
arrivé dans une nouvelle ère ensuite
hier la 4g est là avec son iphone 12
c'est l'ère de la 5g parce que oui c'est
le premier iphone quel la 5g et c'est
pour ça que cet iphone va cartonner et
va vraiment bien se vendre dans le monde
entier alors pas forcément france tout
de suite alors il va se vendre j'en
doute absolument pas parce qu'on a
toujours des bénéfices on va venir
renouveler son smartphone tous les deux
ans les personnes qui sont vraiment fans
d'apple vont venir renouveler pour avoir
le dernier iphone et plus puissant mais
ce qui va surtout être la clé du succès
cet iphone et bien c'est la 5g aux us en
asie qui sont des marchés beaucoup plus
mûr au niveau de la 5g que ce qu'on va
retrouver tout de suite en europe alors
la 5g en tout cas en france pour juste
parler de la france elle va commencer
réellement arrivé en 2021 2021 avec une
évolution sur 2022 donc on va pas
forcément dur aujourd'hui je vais
acheter l'iphone pour avoir de la 5g on
va acheter un iphone de la série 12 pour
avoir un des iphone les plus récents le
plus de performances mais vous allez
voir que les chiffres de ventes en asie
aux us vont littéralement explosé que ça
permettra d'avoir de nouveaux usages on
pourra aller beaucoup plus loin faire
beaucoup plus de choses et ça va être un
vrai point de bascule aujourd'hui chez
apple voilà en tout cas ma vision par
rapport à ses iphone et je suis persuadé
on verra les chiffres en début d'année
prochaine que cet iphone tout cas que
cette gamme d'iphone va cartonner en
plus c'est extrêmement intéressant
comprendre pourquoi ce qu'apple nous
propose quatre nouveaux modèles d'iphone
12 min l'iphone 12 la semaine 12 pro
iphone 12 promax pro déjà on le voit
c'est pour aller plus loin au niveau de
la photo on garde les mêmes processeurs
donc la même performance le max pour
avoir un plus grand écran mais les
usagers sont vraiment là pour moi pour
la photo et le mini est intéressant
parce que il vient vraiment chercher
d'autres personnes qui ne veulent pas
forcément des smartphones avec des
grands écrans donc à pas mal de choses
intéressantes à dessus on va le voir on
va regarder ça on en parlera en baisse
les tester tous et iphone donc je vous
invite à venir vous abonner si ce n'est
pas déjà le cas comme ça vous saurez
tout frais nouveaux iphone d'apple pour
moi en tout cas je vais prendre celui là
il va venir remplacer hop là ce modèle
là je dois me faire un p'tit transfert
de données je vous passe un peu le truc
parce que ça va durer un peu longtemps
mais par contre je pense que toutes les
storage et publié la semaine prochaine
sur instagram seront faites avec cet
iphone là on verra donc un bénéfice au
niveau de la vidéo je ne sais pas s'il
aura bénéfices au niveau de la caméra de
sétif qui était pour moi un des points
un peu négatif de l'iphone aux pros on
se promet axe on n'avait pas de
stabilisation optique la qualité est un
peu plus complexe surtout si vous me
suivez vous savez que je 30 le des mains
donc le fait de ne pas avoir de
stabilisation lorsque génère film et
bien c'est un petit peu rédhibitoire
donc je vous invite également le film
sur instagram pour tout savoir et on va
pouvoir se tester faire plein de photos
etc ce nouvel iphone donc ça va être
très cool sur ce je vous embrasse koné
soin de vous et puis à très très très
vite parce que oui vous le savez je suis
encore en tournage avec amazon pour
l'émission ça va cartonner au tour le
onzième épisode et dernier épisode la
semaine prochaine encore un peu de
balles la droite à gauche espère
compléter quelques petits plans et puis
je serai 100% disponible et 100% avec
vous de retour sur la chaîne donc merci
de votre patience a très vite et puis
beaucoup d'amour surtout car sur vous
des bisous de l'amour a
traîné
la dlep dès ce moment
[Musique]